this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming platform built by
and for creators when you sign up for
curiosity stream at the link below
[Music]
the united states is the richest nation
in the world by far
it would stand to reason that the
population of the us is also the best
compensated for their labor
both in terms of salary or hourly wage
and benefits like vacation time and
parental leave
if you've been watching this channel for
a while you won't be surprised to learn
that's not actually the case
in fact u.s workers are some of the
worst compensated among wealthy nations
and that's just for those who are lucky
enough to find stable work
in this episode we're going to discuss
another problem the constant
unemployment crisis and why american
unemployment numbers are far
worse than they're reported to be let's
go back to the late 1800s when a
statistician named carol wright came up
with a definition for unemployment a
state of being he referred to as
industrial hypochondria for some
historical background
wright was the head of the massachusetts
bureau of labor statistics
and in 1878 he commissioned one of the
very first u.s unemployment surveys
this wasn't simply out of curiosity the
country had suffered a financial panic
in 1873
and five years later the nation was
still very much in a depression
the press had been reporting some very
concerning unemployment numbers
and wright needed to come up with a way
to tamp down potential political unrest
his solution was to redefine
unemployment he tasked the town
assessors and local police with counting
out-of-work citizens but
not all of them in order to suppress the
alarmingly high unemployment figures
wright was concerned only with
able-bodied men over the age of 16
and only those who quote really wanted
to work this of course excluded the many
women and young men who would normally
be working but had since become
unemployed
wright's restrictions and his
intentionally vague men who really
wanted to work
yielded the desired result by carving
out a large portion of the working
population
the report showed considerably lower
unemployment right would go on to become
the first head of the national bureau of
labor statistics
and he took his deceptive definition of
unemployment with him ever since the
1870s
this insufficient definition has been
used to artificially suppress real
unemployment figures
and every time a crisis comes along
elected officials can point to the
overly optimistic numbers and say
see everything is fine if you watch the
news these days
you'll often hear unemployment figures
used as a political weapon
new reports are released pretty
frequently and it's a common tactic for
politicians of both parties
to skew and spin those numbers to fit
their narrative with the presidential
election just around the corner and the
country still reeling from the pandemic
expect unemployment to remain a major
talking point one side will say
unemployment is at unprecedented levels
while still not acknowledging the true
scale of the problem
and the other will say it would be much
worse under opposition leadership
regardless of partisan posturing neither
party is willing to admit that the u.s
unemployment situation is far worse than
it seems
and it's only been getting worse over
the years let's take another look at the
definition of unemployment
to be considered unemployed in the
united states you need to be making zero
dollars from work
and actively be seeking employment that
is constantly applying for jobs
this definition is overly restrictive it
excludes people who earn only a small
amount of money per week
like many gig economy workers it
excludes those who have stopped looking
for work due to the state of the economy
and the lack of jobs
and those who would like to work but
can't because they have to take care of
children
a better definition of unemployment
would be any person who is looking for a
full-time job
that pays a living wage but cannot find
one that living wage part is the most
critical piece to understand
the u.s is notorious for predatory
employment practices
including paying workers far less than
what would be considered a living wage
in the rest of the developed world
for example there is not a single county
in the u.s
not one where a full-time minimum wage
job would cover the expense of renting a
two-bedroom apartment
and in over 95 of those counties a
minimum wage earner couldn't afford a
one bedroom
and that's not even counting other
necessities like food and utilities
this is because the federal minimum wage
hasn't been adjusted to match inflation
or productivity gains in over a decade
the cost of living has gone up
productivity has gone up but the minimum
wage has remained the same
if the minimum wage had simply kept up
with the rate of productivity
it would be over 22 dollars per hour
today
instead it's 7.25 this is only one
example
of the horrific state of labor in the
u.s but it should show you that things
are not as rosy as they're made out to
be
let's apply our new definition of
unemployment to the u.s
in january of 2020 the official
unemployment rate was 3.6
that doesn't sound so bad according to a
recent study by the ludwig institute for
shared economic prosperity
the true rate of unemployment was seven
times that number
a shocking 23.4 percent nearly a quarter
of all americans who want to work
can't find a job that pays a living wage
but wait
that was back in january a few months
later after we completely botched the
coronavirus response and destroyed the
lives of millions of hard-working
americans
the numbers got even worse the latest
numbers indicate
that if we count everybody over the age
of 16 who is actively seeking a living
wage
54.6 percent of americans are unemployed
over half of the entire working
population cannot find a job that will
support them enough to pay the bills
let alone to save for retirement to
start a family or for medical expenses
this is more than just an economic
crisis this is a moral outrage
the fact that over half the population
isn't paid a living wage in the richest
country on earth is a damning indictment
of a predatory system that is growing
worse by the year
treating its own citizens like raw
materials to be consumed by the machine
this isn't a new problem it's been a
slow burning crisis since the 1980s
when worker bargaining power was gutted
and supreme control handed over to
massive corporations
but look those in power say the
unemployment rate is only 8.4 percent
sure that's a little high but it's just
because of the pandemic of course
they know perfectly well that the true
unemployment rate is many times higher
and the only thing
standing between massive unrest and
maintaining the status quo from which
they benefit is spinning the numbers and
lying about the real depth of the
problem
let's take an historical example back in
2008
in the aftermath of the housing crash no
one wanted to admit how bad things had
gotten
seven million americans lost their homes
in what would become known as the worst
financial crisis since the great
depression
in march of 2008 a jobs report came out
which stated
despite the economy shedding 63 000 jobs
unemployment was down from 4.9 percent
to 4.8 percent
how could this be accurate as we saw
earlier the official definition of
unemployment doesn't count those who
have simply given up
and in 2008 there were a lot of
despondent hopeless people
since those people were not actively
applying for jobs since there were no
jobs to be found
they weren't considered unemployed when
the future for millions of americans was
at its most bleak
the official jobs report looked great
this is all part of propagandizing the
population to believe everything is okay
that our country is thriving and that
anyone who wants to work can find a job
to support themselves and their family
this is simply not true to continue our
2008 example
many politicians claimed that
unemployment was below the average of
the last 30 years
if it's lower than in the past how could
it be bad
this may seem like a convincing argument
on the surface but it's deeply
misleading
consider this in the decades leading up
to the crash of 2008
millions more people had begun falling
into the categories not counted by the
official definition of unemployment
as one 2008 article pointed out the
average unemployment rate in this decade
just above five percent
has been lower than in any decade since
the 1960s
yet the percentage of prime age men
those 25 to 54 years old who are not
working has been higher than in any
decade since world war ii
in january almost 13 percent of prime
age men did not hold a job
up from 11 in 1998 11 in 1988
9 in 1978 and just six percent in 1968.
even prime age women who flooded into
the workforce in the 1970s and 1980s
aren't working at quite the same rate
they were when this decade began
about 27 percent of them don't hold a
job today up from 25
in early 2000 so the number of
unemployed people was increasing
but the unemployment rate was going down
how was this possible
in short people were being left behind
by the economy
many jobs were being shipped overseas
others were becoming automated
and workers without the bargaining power
their grandparents had suddenly found
themselves only receiving offers of half
what they had earned before
this growing group those seeking work
but unable to find a reasonable wage has
only continued to grow
since 2008. massive corporations and the
very wealthy rebounded from the crash
just fine
banks were bailed out executives faced
no consequences
politicians spun the recession as a
fluke all those homes that were
foreclosed upon
they were snatched up at bargain prices
by real estate companies and the wealthy
and to this day they're held hostage on
the rental market what we're left with
today is a dystopian labor landscape
you have to work to survive but even
that is no longer a guarantee
as new quote innovative industries pop
up workers are finding fewer and fewer
jobs that will even classify them as
employees
if you're a gig economy worker an uber
driver for example
you're racking up miles on your own car
driving absurd hours to make pennies and
the company does not provide you with
any benefits because you're not an
employee
then when your car breaks down and you
have to spend all the money you've made
to get it fixed
where does that leave you uber certainly
won't help you're just a cog in their
machine
it's the perfect scam and other
parasites who fancy themselves savvy
business people are eager to get in on
the action
the gig economy is just the most recent
example of how the labor market has
destroyed the earning potential of
american workers
traditional jobs won't pay you a living
wage but you need to pay the bills so
you think maybe if you just work long
enough hours driving for lyft you can
get ahead
then you find yourself trapped in the
gig economy still making less than a
living wage
with no health care no benefits no
vacation and no way to save for the
future
all the while politicians will tell you
that the unemployment rate is only 8.4
so it must be your own fault for not
finding suitable work
don't fall for it the true unemployment
rate is almost 30
percent or over 50 percent if you
include younger workers
the economy doesn't work for workers and
we need to be aware of just how bad the
situation
actually is if you've watched my last
few videos
you'll have noticed that youtube has
been demonetizing a lot of them that's
why some of my creator friends and i
teamed up to build nebula
a streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me so we don't have to
worry about demonetization
since nebula is all about creating
thoughtful content we've partnered with
curiositystream an established streaming
platform with a solid track record of
caring about great educational content
and the financial security of those who
produce it
curiosity stream is an online streaming
service with thousands of nonfiction
titles from some of the best filmmakers
in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
the future of work which offers a
fascinating look at what work could be
like in the decades to come
as educational creators ourselves we
love curiositystream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiositystream at the link
below
you'll also get access to nebula 100
free for a limited time
curiosity stream is offering 26 off
their annual plan
that's less than 15 bucks a year for
both curiosity stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time learning about
fascinating topics on curiosity stream
or check out nebula's exclusive content
including my upcoming series on the
resurgence of fascism you can also watch
all my videos as they were intended
ad free there really is something for
everyone and by signing up at the link
below you're helping us produce more
content without the fear of
demonetization give curiosity stream a
shot and get free access to nebula when
you sign up using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week